-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"why I'm single" stories
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's from @RickyP3rd
He says...
[ Audience "aww"s ]
-RickyP3rd...
-Yeah.
This one's from @SweatyBetty.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, there you go.
-No, that's not the reason.
-Oh, I'm sorry.
-That's not the reason
why she's single.
No.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughs ] What?
This one is from
@tidewoddergirl.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
I like this.
-My eyes!
This...
This one's from @Keirstinyo.
-Yo!
-She says...
[ Laughter ]
What?
-"New Brittany".
-The new...
You're new Brittany. Oh, gosh.
- Oops. You did it again.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @ninjamandr1221.
He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's kind of brilliant.
-Genius.
-That's kind of genius.
-Yeah.
-[ Chuckles ] God.
-Like a trough.
-Yeah, I love it.
-Yeah...
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
This one's from
@itsShyyyyyyyyyy.
She says...
He's like, "No,
do you have the date?"
-No...
-Do you have the date?
Oh, God.
-"Date". Oof.
This last one's from
@GrandpaBerty.
-Ohh.
-She says...
-Oh, there you go.
Oh, my God.
Those are our "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.come/hastags.